everyone expects some props to be
destroyed during a film shoot every once
in a while though something breaks that
no one expected or budgeted for these
are the costliest things destroyed while
making movies historic toilets and all
when Jennifer Jason Leigh watched in
horror as Kurt Russell smashes a replica
of an authentic 1870s marching guitar in
the hateful eight her reaction was
entirely real because Russell
unknowingly destroyed the actual Martin
and not the replica someone forgot to
swap the real guitar for the prop Lee
told Billboard Kurt felt terrible he had
no idea when he found out his eyes
literally welled up Lee was heartbroken
she'd just learned to play guitar on
that Martin and she'd even been allowed
to take it home to practice before she
learned it was a museum piece Liat even
inquired about the price she was
interested in taking at home once
production was done Martin guitar museum
director dick Boak told reverb that the
museum quote will no longer loan
guitarrist movies under any
circumstances Skyfall
the third James Bond movie to be filmed
in Istanbul might be the last film there
after a stunt man crashed a motorcycle
into a three hundred thirty year old
jewelry shop the opening chase sees Bond
pursuing the villainous Patrice across
the rooftops of Istanbul it culminates
in a dramatic crash through a breakable
prop window into the tight vibrant
corridors of the Grand Bazaar what you
don't see is the immediate aftermath
swerving to avoid packed throngs of
extras the stuntmen lost control of his
bike and smashed right through the real
crystal blast window of a historic
jewellery shop it's incredible how much
preparation went into this scene and how
things went awry
anyway production manager Banderas Damir
described the process to the guide
Istanbul before shooting we had to
negotiate and convince 1650 shop owners
in the area of the Grand Bazaar the
Spice Bazaar and in-between the crew
also had to secure countless permits
from Turkey's Ministry of Culture
Transportation Commission and Istanbul's
Police Department finally the stunt was
rehearsed several times to ensure it
would go
off without a hitch meatboy be the shops
owner said repairs were costly
complicated and resulted in lost revenue
he explained Reuters this place is
regulated by the Council of monuments we
can't even change our window without
their permission he also revealed the
response from the sky Falls production
no one from the movie crew came to ask
what are your losses we filed the
complaint at the police station in a
thrilling scene in Christopher Nolan's
legendary 2008 movie The Dark Knight the
Joker and his gang divert and trap a
SWAT escort in a tight underpass they
managed to destroy several vans and even
a police helicopter Batman enters the
fray in his Batmobile having just taken
out a few parked cars himself it's a
chaotic exciting sequence captured with
close kinetic camera movements
unfortunately according to shortlist
those camera movements also resulted in
the destruction of an IMAX camera
breaking a camera during production
happens IMAX cameras are in another
league though the manufacturer typically
just rents out their cameras they're so
expensive most movie productions
wouldn't be able to afford them
otherwise how expensive are they a
single IMAX camera costs $500,000
according to premium beef that's right
half a million dollars for one camera
half a million is nothing to sneeze at
but given how profitable the movie was
that's a cost easily written off but
there wasn't another wrinkle in 2008
IMAX cameras were very rare we're
talking count on one hand and half a
finger left over rare yep
Nolan broke just one of four IMAX
cameras in the world at the time
Christopher Nolan doesn't have just one
destroyed IMAX camera to his name during
production on 2012's The Dark Knight
Rises another IMAX camera was destroyed
the movie centers around a conflict
between Batman and Bane a criminal
mastermind who imposes martial law on
Gotham City this culminates in a massive
fight on the steps of Gotham City Hall
Catwoman rides the Batpod motorcycle out
of the building down the steps and
directly into an IMAX camera the
motorcycle isn't moving particularly
fast but the stunt woman and the
cameraman didn't realize they were
annika
course and the IMAX camera was knocked
right out of his hand another $500,000
down the drain at least this time the
number of IMAX cameras in the world had
finally climbed at double digits andrei
tarkovsky 'he's 1986 film the sacrifice
takes the cake for accidental
destruction that film burned down a
whole house twice to be fair burning
down the house was intentional less
intentional was the camera jamming the
crew was filming from a distance his
flames rip viciously through the house
people hustled about shouting orders
before it became abundantly clear what
happened Tarkovsky was filmed covering
his face with both hands and moaning as
the house burned uselessly Tarkovsky
said the last thing I expected was for
the camera crew to screw up the house
was rebuilt I'll be at a great expense
and the scene refilmed the movie went on
to be a classic but it's unlikely anyone
forgot the moment the awful truth of the
first houses destruction was revealed
while king Phoenix has never been afraid
to go well beyond what's written in the
script sometimes that results in an
injury to himself as in Joker where the
actors so embodied his role he
dislocated his knee while filming a
scene as reported by comic book calm in
the master Phoenix's character Freddie
quell is thrown into a jail cell
adjacent to philip Seymour Hoffman's
Lancaster Dodd sending quell into a rage
hands cuffed behind his back Phoenix
crashes wildly in a Cell he violently
throws himself repeatedly into the top
bunk bed kicks at the door and finally
stomps the toilet
the first stop dislodges it but the
second sends it into the ground where it
shatters instantly director Paul Thomas
Anderson told indieWIRE that
unfortunately was a real porcelain
toilet a historic toilet we can only do
it once
Phoenix told the New York Times he drew
inspiration from wild animals and
captivity that reacts so viscerally that
they often end up hurting themselves he
said I didn't intend to break the thing
I didn't know that was possible
in an episode from the third season of
Battlestar Galactica Edward James almost
broke a model ship and an
emotionally-charged
bit of improvisation unfortunately they
forgot to tell almost that the model
ship wasn't a prop
but instead was an original borrowed
from a museum almost told the crowd at
the 2012 planet Comicon I said what did
you put it in the scene for I mean God
Almighty I've just been told that my
daughter's dead what are you nuts that
original he reduced the kindling it was
reportedly worth a cool $200,000 check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]